los residentes que regresan están
haciendo un balance de los daños después
de que las tropas rusas se retiraran de
los alrededores de kiev en versifica a
50 kilómetros al oeste de la capital los
restos de los tanques rusos cubren la
carretera la ciudad sufrió un intenso
bombardeo y se destruyeron
infraestructuras clave como la red
eléctrica los residentes están enfadados
por el nivel de daños pero dicen que
pueden reconstruir
estamos vivos eso es lo más importante
las casas y los coches no son tan
importantes no pueden destruir nuestra
nación y nuestra alma
en otra ciudad de las afueras de kiev
los residentes entierran a sus muertos
las autoridades ucranianas dicen que se
han encontrado más de 1200 cadáveres en
los pueblos de los alrededores de la
capital tras la retirada del ejército
ruso el gobierno afirman que las
acciones de rusia en ucrania constituyen
crímenes de guerra mientras los
investigadores documentan casos de
tortura y ejecuciones extrajudiciales
en circos que webs y seres kofl y alexei
nació en 1990 fue llevado como
prisionero de guerra su cuerpo fue
encontrado ocho días después el equipo
forense nos había dicho que había sido
torturado y que luego fue asesinado de
un solo disparo en la cabeza
continúan los encarnizados combates
entre las fuerzas rusas y el ejército
ucraniano cerca de mariupol en el
sureste del país el presidente de
volodymyr selenski dijo que hay decenas
de miles de muertos en la ciudad
portuaria
y no puede haber esperanza de que rusia
simplemente se detenga por sí sola y no
puede haber esperanza de que la razón
prevalezca y las autoridades rusas
simplemente se niegan a continuar esta
guerra desde la autoproclamada república
popular de dones aseguran que se
intensificarán los combates en el
donbass mientras que el ejército
ucraniano se prepara para una pronta
ofensiva rusa